[موسيقى]
جزاء الغيم تنهمر الحروف
لها نغم يحس به الشغوف
يرى فيها غصوننا باسقات
على اطرافها تدنو القطوف
فان لبثت مقاليد المعاني مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوقوف
[موسيقى]
ساقضي ببيتا يحمد الناس امره ويكثر من اهل
الروايه قائله يموت ردي الشعر من قبل اهله
وجيده يبقى ولو مات قائله السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
ما الفرق بين العمى والعمى العمه في لغه
العرب هو عمل بصيره خاصه اما العمى بالالف
المقصوره يطلق على عمل بصر والبصيره على
السواء يقول تعالى فانها لا تعمل ابصار
ولكن تعمل قلوب التي في الصدور والعمه
بالهاء تعذر الادراك والتحير في الامر
والتردد في الضلال يقول تعالى ان الذين لا
يؤمنون بالاخره زينا لهم اعمالهم فهم
يعمهون ويقول تعالى الله يستهزئ بهم
ويمدهم في طغيانهم يعمهون يقول الشاعر
حيران يعمه في ضلالته مستورد
لشرائع الظلم
قال بعض اهل اللغه ان العمى للبصيره
كالعمى للبصر ويقول الشاعر اراني قد عملت
وشاب راسي وهذا اللعب شين للكبير وقال بعض
المفسرين من عميت بصيرته لم ير حقا من
باطل ولم يميز حسنا من قبيح ولا نافعا
منظار
اراني قد عملت وشاب راسي وهذا اللعب شين
للكبير
[موسيقى]
اذا خشع جبار الارض
رحم جبار السماء
روى الذهبي في سير اعلام النبلاء ان
السماء اجدبت في الاندلس على عهد الخليفه
الناصر فامر القاضي منذر بن سعيد البلوطي
ان يخرج بالناس الى الاستسقاء فقال القاضي
لغلامه قبل ان يخرج اذهب فانظر ماذا يصنع
امير المؤمنين فعاد فقال ما رايت قط اخشع
منه في يومه هذا انه منفرد بنفسه لابس
اخشن ثيابه مفترس التراب قد على نحيبه
واعترافه بذنوبه ويقول ربي هذه ناصيتي
بيدك اتراك تعذب الرعيه وانت احكم
الحاكمين واعدلهم اللهم ان كنت اذنبت فلا
تهلك الناس بذنبي فتهلل القاضي وقال يا
غلام احمل الممطر معك اذا خشع جبار الارض
رحم جبار السماء فخرج فاستسقى فجاء المطر
والممطر هو الرداء المشمع الذي يدفع المطر
كانوا من شده الثقه بالله سبحانه انهم اذا
ذهبوا حتى يستسقوا ياخذون معهم ما يحجب
عنهم المطر الغزير
وهذا خلق حري بنا ان نتخلق به عندما ندعو
الله فنكون موقنين بالاجابه
[موسيقى]
تقول العرب القيت له الحبل على الغارب اي
اعطيته الحريه في ان يصنع ما يشاء والغارب
هو الظهر وكان صاحب الناقه اذا اراد ان
يطلقها لترعى بحريه رمى حبلها على ظهرها
اي على الغارب ذلك ان الناقه لا ترعى جيدا
اذا رات الحبل متدليا من عنقها طول الوقت
ومن التعابير التي قل استعمالها في يومنا
قولك استغرب ضاحكا لا نجد علاقه بين
التعجب وبين الضحك هنا استغرب معناها
استلقى على غاربه اي على ظهره يكون المرء
جالسا على الارض ويسمع حديثا مضحكا فيضحك
طويلا حتى يستلقي على ظهره
يقال لا يكن حبك كلفا ولا بغضك تلفا
وقالوا لا يضيق سم الخياط بمتحابين ولا
تسع الدنيا متباغضين
ويقال لا تصحب الجاهل فانه يريد ان ينفعكم
فيضركم وقالوا من عرض نفسه للتهم فلا يامن
من اساءه الظن وقالوا العين باب القلب فما
كان في القلب
ظهر في العين ان العيون على القلوب شواهد
فبغيظها لكبين وحبيبها
[موسيقى]
من الكلمات التي تدل على انواع القطع في
العربيه نقول بث الكلام وصرم الموده وهجر
الصديق وحصد الزرع وقصله وجز النبات وقطف
العنب وخضد النخل وجده وقصب اللحم وبضعه
وهبره وقرض الشيطولا وقطه عرضا
هناك بدائل عربيه لكلمات اعجميه اشتهرت
على السنه الناس
الاتوبيس مثلا قد يكون بديلها العربي
الحافله
والموتوسيكل يكون بديلها الدراجه واللانش
بديلها الزورق والونش بديلها الرافعه
والشاسيه بديلها الهيكل
والاستبن او الاسبير بديلها العربي
الاحتياط
[موسيقى]
يقول المثل اينما اوجه القصعدا فما قصه
هذا المثل
زعموا ان الارض ابن قريع بن عوف السعدي
التميمي كان يرى من قومه وهو سيدهم جفوه
وبغيا عليه وتنقصا له فقال ما في مجامعتها
هؤلاء خير واني مفارقهم ففارقهم وسار
باهله حتى نزل بديار قوم اخرين فاذا هم
يفعلون باشرافهم كما كان يفعل به قومه من
اذيه وتنقص وشتم وباغي فارتحل عنهم وحل
باخرين فاذا هم كذلك فلما راى ذلك انصرف
وقال ما ارى الناس الا قريبا بعضهم من بعض
فتوجهت القاء قومه وقال اينما اوجه القسعه
فارسل لها مثلها
ويروى في كل واد بنو سعد وهنا نصافح طرفه
ابن العبد حين تخلى عنه قومه وقت الشدائد
فقال اسلمني قومي ولم يغضبوا لسوئه حلت
بهم فادحه كل خليل كنت خاللته لا ترك الله
له واضحه كلهم اروغ من ثعلب ما اشبه
الليله بالبارحه
والواضحه السن التي تظهر عند الضحك
[موسيقى]
يقولون الصوم محتم علينا والصواب ان نقول
الصوم محتوم علينا باسم المفعول من الفعل
حتم حتم اي اوجب والصوم حتم مقضي بالمصدر
من الحتم وهو مصدر ثلاثي يقول الله تعالى
وان منكم الا واردها كان على ربك حتما
مقضيا الفعل الرباعي حتما بالتضعيف لم يرد
عن العرب وانما ورد الثلاثي حتما
يقولون هذا الشيء يلمع يخطف البصر فيكسرون
الطاء ويقولون في الماضي خطفا والافصح ان
نقول يخطف بفتح الطاء وبه جاء التنزيل
الحكيم يقول تعالى يكاد البرق يخطف
ابصارهم
يقولون
يغص المنزل بالضيوف ويغص الملعب بالجمهور
بضم الغين يريدون انه يمتلئ والافصح ان
نقول يغص واصله من الضيق ومنه قول الترماح
غصت عليك الارض قحطان بالقناه
وبالهندوانيات والقرح الجردي
[موسيقى]
كان شريح عند زياد بن ابيه وهو مريض فلما
خرج شريح من الزياره ارسل اليه مسروق بن
عبد الرحمن رسولا يساله كيف تركت الامير
فقال شريح تركته يامر وينهى قال مسروق
للرسول انه صاحب مرض فارجع اليه واساله ما
يامر وما ينهى فرجع اليه فقال يامر
بالوصيه وينهى عن النوح
وذلك بيان وايجاز وبلاغه
[موسيقى]
تختزل الزمن وتلغي المسافات
تسهل الحاضر وتقرب المستقبل
تنقلنا الى عوالم اخرى
وتحول الخيال الى حقيقه
تترك ابوابنا
وتقتحم منازلنا دون اذن
التكنولوجيا اسرتنا وما زالت تبهرنا كل
يوم
حياه ذكيه اليوم في السابعه والنصف مساء
بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
[موسيقى]
كنت قد سالتكم في تويتر ماذا قالت العرب
عن الجمال وفيما يلي استعرض معكم بعض ما
وصلني من مشاركاتكم هذه مشاركه من عبد
الله دلي يقول احمد شوقي سلو قلبي غداه
سلا وتاب لعل على الجمال له عتابا
ومشاركه من يوسف كل النساء امام حسنك صوره
وجمالك الاصل الاصيل الاصدقاء
هنا مشاركه ايضا من ايناس تقول فلولا
النفوس التي تدرك قيمه الجمال ما وجدت على
الارض تلك النفوس او ما وجدت على الارض
نفوسا تدرك قيمه الخير وهل هذا الخير الا
بعض جمال النفس
الرافعي
بلال يقول لله سر جمال ان انت موضعه
والسر حيث يشاء الله يودعه ابن سهل
الاندلسي
سجاد الطائي يقول صوني جمالك عنا اننا بشر
من التراب وهذا الحسن روحاني احمد شوقي
صار نجيم ساقت حديث النبي عليه الصلاه
والسلام ان الله جميل يحب الجمال طبعا هذا
الحديث وربما تكون هذه مناسبه من اجل ان
نوضح ان هذا الجزء هو مقطع من حديث كانت
بدايته قول النبي عليه الصلاه والسلام لا
يدخل الجنه من كان في قلبه مثقال ذره من
كبر ثقيل ان الرجل يحب ان يكون ثوبه حسنا
ونعله حسنه فقال حينها ردا على هذا الكلام
ان الله جميل يحب الجمال واوضح عليه
الصلاه والسلام ان الكبر بطل الحق وغمط
الناس فهنا
ياتي سياق هذا المقطع من الحديث
مشاركه من اخلاص والبيت لذي الرمه وعينان
قال الله كنا فكانتا فعولان بالالباب ما
تفعل السحر
اما انا فاقول انت اختصرت جمال كل بثينه
وانا احاول ان اكون جميله اشكر لكم هذه
المشاركات وهذا التفاعل
[موسيقى]
هذا شاعر قال اول برده عرفها الشعر العربي
هي البرده الحقيقيه فقد نال عليها برده
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
بانت سعاد فقلب اليوم متبول متيم اثرها لم
يفد مكبول كثيرا ما يورث الوالد ولده
صناعته والشعر في جانب منه صناعه كان زهير
بن ابي سلمى الشاعر الجاهلي المشهور صاحب
معلقه وقضى ظرف صعب وخطر على ابنه كعب ان
يكون صاحب قصيده لها شهره المعلقات
كان زهير محترفا ورب ابناءه على الشعر
لكنه منع كعبا وهو انبغهم من قول الشعر
قبل ان يشتد عوده ولكن كعبا ظل يقول البيت
والبيتين وكان ابوه يضربه ويحبسه ويحرمه
ثم ذات مره ركب زهير جملا واردف ابنه كعبا
وراءه واخذ الجمل يهملج ويعدو وراح زهير
يقول الشطر من الشعر فيسمع من ولده الشطر
الثاني الذي يتم به المعنى وانتهت الرحله
بان سمح زهيرا لولده بقول الشعر عندما بلغ
كعب مبالغ الرجال كان الاسلام قد اشتد
وكان الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم قد اسس
الدوله الاسلاميه في المدينه
فاما زهير فكان قد مات وكان اول من اسلم
من ابنائه بجير لكن كعبا تلكئ لا بل كتب
الى اخيه بجير ابياتا يلومه فيها على
الدخول في الاسلام
فاهدر النبي دم كعب فاختفى وضاقت الدنيا
في وجهه ثم ان اخاه بجيرا بعث اليه ينصحه
بان يفد على النبي ويسلم فورد كعب المدينه
سرا وقصد مسجد النبي متخفيا متلثما وبعد
صلاه الفجر اسفر عن وجهه واشهر اسلامه
فامله النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
فانشده قصيدته في مدحه وهي تبدا على
عادتهم بالنسيب اي الغزل الرقيق
بانت سعاد فقلب اليوم متبول متيم اثرها لم
يخدم مكبول وما سعاد غداه البين اذ رحلوا
الا اغن غضيض الطرف مكحول
ويصف كعب بن زهير سعاد فهي هيفاء ولها بطن
لها وهي عجزاء ممتلئه اذا ادبرت
هيفاء مقبله عجزاء مدبره لا يشتكى قصر
منها ولا طول
يقول
ولا تمسكوا بالوصل الذي زعمت الا كما تمسك
الماء الغرابيل امست سعاد بارض لا يبلغها
الا العتاق النجيبات المراسيل يسعى الوشاه
بجنبيها وقولهم انك يا ابن ابي سلمان
مقتول فقلت خلوا سبيلي لا ابا لكم فكل ما
قدر الرحمن مفعول
ثم يصل الى هذا البيت الذي صار مضربا
للمثل
كل ابن انثى وان طالت سلامته يوما على اله
حدباء محمول امبئت ان رسول الله اوعدني
والعفو عند رسول الله مامول مهلا هداك
الذي اعطاك نافله القران فيها مواعيظ
وتفصيل لا تاخذني باقوال الوشاعه ولم اذنب
ولو كثرت في الاقاويل ان الرسول لنور
يستضاء به مهند من سيوف الله مسلول في
عصبه من قريش قال قائلهم ببطن مكه لما
اسلموا زولوا
ان الرسول لنور يستضاء به مهند من سيوف
الله مسلول عليه الصلاه والسلام
[موسيقى]
في يوم العيد
ذهبت كي اهنئ احد الاصدقاء بعد صلاه العيد
فوجدت باب مجلسه مغلقا وعلمت انه كان
مسافرا فكتبت في ذلك اقول
حسبي ولو الفيت بابك مغلقا ان باب وجودك
دائما مفتوح
ان حاله الاسفار دون لقائنا فقصائد تلقاك
حيث تروح بالروح قبل الجسم جئت مهنئا
بالعيد فاسلم
اعافدتك الروح السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]